ابح ابحاث علماء صواريخ روسيه التي تفوق
سرعتها سرعه الصوت قد تنهار وفق رساله
تحذيريه ارسلوها الكرملين اما السبب
فيعودوا لاجهزه الامن الروسيه التي اعتقلت
الكثير من هؤلاء العلماء بتهمه الخيانه ما
قد يوقف العمل في مركز الابحاث في سيبيريا
مثلا في الرساله المفتوحه المنشوره على
الموقع الالكتروني لمعهد الميكانيكا
النظريه والتطبيقيه حث العلماء الحكومه
والشعب الروسي على انقاذ عقود من عمل
العلماء السوفيات والروس من الانهيار
الوشيك اهم من تم اعتقالهم وفقا المعهد
ناتولي مسلوب وهو فيزيائي متخصص في
ديناميكا الهوائيه ويبلغ من العمر 76 عاما
ولدينا ايضا
مختبر تكنولوجيا الصواريخ الفائقه السرعه
وهو يبلغ من العمر 56 عاما ونذهب ايضا الى
عالم ديناميكا الهوائيه الثالث فاليري
اعتقل الشهر الماضي هؤلاء العلماء الثلاثه
وصفهم اولائهم بالعباقره كفاءاتهم وسمعتهم
المهنيه ان تسمح لهم بالعثور على وظائف
مرموقه اجور جيده في الخارج ان ارادوا ذلك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات